she started a free summer camp to help
students get ready for middle school
every month she spends up to 200
of her own paycheck on food and supplies
for her students
and if that wasn't enough on the weekend
she gives a free act prep class
she is the definition of a superhero
melody hawkins i'm sorry we haven't been
truthful with you but it's all for good
reasons come on out here
oh i've been waiting to meet you you've
been waiting to meet me
i have i've been so excited about
this wonderful encounter and i've just
been reading about your life and
everything that you do here sit down
i'll see you sneak prep your chair thank
you i like it just want to make it
perfect for you
i mean you've been in education for
seven years
and
this originally was not necessarily the
path what were you going to do i wanted
to be a doctor
that was that was my dream all through
middle school into high school college
that's what i was working towards and
when i spent time after graduation with
the americorps i was a volunteer in new
orleans louisiana
and yeah thank you
i i fell in love with helping kids
i i i had i started to develop this real
passion for seeing kids grow and thrive
and be themselves and be their authentic
selves and it really pushed me to want
to be more authentic about who i was so
i decided i needed to make a pivot in my
career did you have teachers growing up
that like impacted the relationship that
you
matriculate down onto your students
absolutely
my first teacher that i ever had is my
mom my mom's a teacher um so education
has always been in my family well what
do you think um that your students you
know think of you
do you have any idea how they might feel
about you and your teaching i i have
some idea um
i would say um and i actually have to
draw back uh to an encounter that i had
with one of my students who has actually
since passed on
my school community has been through a
lot my students my teachers their
families we've been through a lot and i
had a student who wrote a beautiful note
to me it's been about three years ago
now i think and it was the the most
beautiful note i've ever gotten and she
just told me how my smile made her feel
welcomed every day to come to school
and she told me that she always
appreciated seeing me and sometimes she
would have a hard morning but she would
see me and it would make her feel better
this beautiful beautiful note and i i
cherish it um
because she actually passed away
due to gun violence in our community and
that was the first student i ever lost
and then seeing my other students having
to pick themselves up and keep going
like nothing ever happened
it actually it it made me even more
charged to keep going and i
i do what i do with her in mind i keep
her picture with me um it goes with me
everywhere i go it's on my on my phone
well um i'm very glad that you carry her
with you thank you and that you honor
her life and that you know she inspired
you so much and
um if it's okay um we actually have
something to show you so
ms hawkins is the best teacher i call
her mama now because she has become sort
of another figure in my life that helps
guide me through school she always made
it fun like she came in with good energy
every day i think what makes melody a
great educator is just her quest for
excellence she cares so deeply
about
what she's doing every day miss shaw
kids made me feel
like i was really the best kid in the
world she made me feel like i could
actually be someone in life why do you
think she deserves appreciation because
she's hard working
it's okay
did you have these good tears
it sounds like she means a lot of feet
yeah she do yeah
because i mean a lot to her she was the
best teacher for her i love to see
you off in the world doing these amazing
things she is going to be someone who
affects education in this country melody
keep shining we love you and we are so
proud of you we love you miss hawkins we
love you miss hawkins oh my gosh
and something really exciting um
happened recently you won the southeast
regional national university teacher
award
so you pulled regional you're like
that's me i won this
and you're up for a national award too
right when do you find out about that
i'm not exactly sure they said early
2022 so
i don't know well
actually um you're here today because
you are the winner
[Applause]
from the national university
there is something else too are you
ready for this no yeah no i guess
actually one better you're also
receiving a full ride scholarship to
national universities doctorate program
so
that you can continue your education
that is so exciting
congratulations melody hawkins go to our
website to learn more about the national
university teacher award and melody's
incredible story we'll be right back
[Music]
you